I think the only thing that matters in
the world is who's the best at gardening
attention the end there's no other
currency it's how the whole world's
always worked Mr Beast couldn't be a
threat to Hershey's Logan Paul couldn't
be a threat to Gatorade the influencer
that I'm most worried about for you in
the next five years couldn't be a threat
to you because they didn't have enough
scale to compete with you you didn't
have enough scale to compete with PNG
and unever at that level now a single
human can screw you all up because she
can reach everyone for nothing zero she
doesn't have to run commercials and she
doesn't need the retailer she doesn't
need Walmart Walmart is taking your
money to give to people like her to
seduce her to come into the store cuz
they need her shit's changed attention
is the number one
asset